this video is being made solely at your
request there's a lot of things that
shouldn't be happening in this video and
this is a hollywood production set so
i'm hoping that proper medical care was
given afterwards at the very least it's
going to get rough it's going to get
weird we're going to react to it pee
whoop
what are you gonna be doing today
hit somebody in the nuts
francis hits harder than any heavyweight
in mma like i've been hit by ryan garcia
bryan garcia is like 140 150 pounds this
gentleman is like 200 200 plus no i told
aaron it was a lightweight
i didn't tell him it was a heavy weight
jeff and i forgot to mention that that's
not a [__] lightweight what are you
talking about
this is the cup test before he punches
this is gonna be brutal to watch the
painful area is a testicular area that
will get you nauseous that will be
terrible if he hits with an uppercut
that can trap the testicle against the
pubic bone it can actually cause a
testicular rupture i hope that's not
what happens
oh my god
is that the hardest you've ever hit
someone in the ding ding oh yeah
forget about the pressure on the the
general area the cup actually going into
the bones there the sides of the plastic
cup and this is the softball test
okay
[Music]
wow the accuracy of it i mean this can
cause you to become infertile this is
not a fun game for anyone to play like
you could actually get develop a
hematoma in this area that is a surgical
emergency here we are at some random ass
ranch
and this is the brand ready oh no
why do they do this with a peen please
tell me they're gonna disinfect the skin
clean them up
oh
that's not really no disinfecting
doesn't mean wiping with a dirty towel
oh
those are some serious burns there
because he burned past the epidermis
he's in the dermal layer there when you
have serious burns throughout your
entire body the biggest risk is
dehydration because your skin isn't able
to maintain the moisture of your body
you have electrolyte disturbances and
hydrating the patient and constantly
checking those electrolytes is of utmost
importance what am i looking at he gave
me a dick farm on my ass oh that looks
infective that needs oral antibiotics
you're gonna have that for life no shh
if you're having fun watching this
reaction you're gonna have fun watching
me on stage going to these four cities
boston philly dc red bank new jersey
click down below for tickets all right
let's get back to jackass but today i'm
going to treat myself to some wasabi
snooters
i remember watching this this is old by
the way wasabi in the u.s is usually
just horseradish that's been dyed green
and the reason that it kind of makes you
tear up and it affects your nostrils is
because it's smaller than the capsaicin
molecules that normally trigger the
spiciness on your tongue so it actually
gets up into your nose
i just had sushi too so this makes it so
much worse oh he throws up so what we're
going to do is extract aaron's crooked
tooth and then we're going to replant it
just like he would a tree no that's not
how it works though i'm danger aaron and
this is the lamborghini tooth pull oh no
one you could not pull the tooth out
correctly and if there's decay there the
tooth can crack you could actually pull
the tooth out so much so that you could
damage the bone that the tooth is
attached to or you could sever the gum
and when you sever the gum you should
have crazy bleeding are you stoked i
hope it's loose already
[Music]
[Applause]
that sounded like it was a healthy tooth
why did they pull out a healthy tooth i
wish i could say that didn't suck
that was worse than the tom hanks scene
from castaway a lot of doctors they
think they're god you know
not me yeah cause you got a
four-year-old stethoscope on your neck
champ for our next challenge our friend
jules here is going to help poopies kiss
this deadly viper
what kind of snake is it uh venomous
i hate when people say eh i asked that
to the person the animal keeper at the
last place i was at i was like is it
venomous he's like yeah fm is like an
ant bite i was like what does that mean
move your head closer closer
oh
okay snakes don't have rabies they're
not like bats but they do have tetanus
you can get a tooth stuck in you because
it dislodges confidence is very very
high with our third contestant stevo for
the skateboard guillotine
where is that gonna fall
i hope not on his neck
shin bone
oh my god shin's getting hit like that
so many nerve endings firing bad
memories from taekwondo when i was
younger oh my god
shinzo shin contact i'm butterbaiting
every day we're going to do a little
boxing oh okay little boxing action i'll
take it touch gloves and come out
fighting
i don't think he has a mobile belt oh
bad form
bad for no punching to the back of the
head that's the occipital region give me
one you lose there you go
oh my god all right that second hit is
the most dangerous hit because at that
point you're not protected you have no
muscle tone you're just completely
flaccid that allows more of that
ricochet feeling oh i think he hit his
head on one of the counters i don't know
apparently i have a big gash in my head
and i think i'm a little concussed well
a big gash in the head surprisingly
isn't usually fixed by sutures it's
fixed by staples that's right we have a
special staple gun that instead of
pushing down the staples it kind of
wraps the staples around your skin and
then to remove it we just kind of fold
the staple outwards this is super mighty
glue who's got tummy hair
not me are they going to wax him
no i think i think this is going to work
all right are you ready now
and he's putting pressure on first of
all spoiler alert they're not going to
be able to pull these hands off and it's
not going to just pull the hair off with
it this is potential skin tearing thank
god they're not older because older
patients will tear their skin off
oh maybe they did take up stairs they
exfoliated the gentleman's chest
somebody go get me the stun gun no
oh look at his skin terry look at his
skin tearing ah
look at my [__] nipple
oh
did he know yeah man good job what did
he just got into a car accident and
going from whatever miles per hour he
was driving to zero is actually the most
dangerous because that inertia will keep
your organs moving keep your brain
moving so they hit against your chest
wall you get some serious blood force
trauma that way this is electric avenues
are those tasers each one of these stun
guns has 950 000 volts that's a lot of
volts and also they're like quick
touches as opposed to sustained
pressures oh police issued stun guns or
tasers have 50 000 volts and the ones
that have been tested by police they can
become problematic when you're already
on other substances or if you have an
existing heart condition but generally
the purpose of them is to overwhelm your
central nervous system so much so that
you have no control and you go limp and
you can actually be subdued and we found
a leech healer and these boys need a
little healing let's see what they can
do for my eyeball like if i was to vote
on the worst place to put a leech it
would probably be your eyeball leeches
bite that's how they're actually able to
suck blood they have chemicals in there
that actually prevent coagulation of
blood so they can keep draining you of
blood some of them can be beneficial in
patients who have a clotting disorder
and patients who have a lot of
inflammation but the eye is not the
place where you want that to happen oh
my god just he's going to start bleeding
into his eye this is terrible corneal
abrasions so many problems can happen if
it's not a regulated leech
this is terrible
you scratch your cornea that requires
like instant treatment otherwise it can
become problematic you could actually
start bleeding into your eye creating a
little pocket of bleeding and that's
just not an area where you want pressure
to build up because that could very
quickly start affecting your vision and
potentially permanently this is the butt
shot oh yeah i already don't like it i
don't like a funnel oh no he's doing
this you really gotta get in there enema
with alcohol
oh open wide oh my god you know it's
like they're laughing at this but this
is actually a real problem because you
get drunk quicker and it's actually
really problematic for two reasons first
is that you you lose the first pass uh
metabolism of the alcohol when you drink
your liver is able to clean it out
before it starts going to your uh
bloodstream if you over enema yourself
with too much alcohol you can't vomit
and you could actually cause severe
severe alcohol intoxication 18 year olds
in college parties have done this and
ended up having lethal seizures it's
really problematic how many bee stings
do you think we can take
i think it takes about 100 to kill man
that is not accurate the official number
is like 10 per pound of body weight so
like the average human can take over
like a thousand stings and be okay also
that's keeping in mind if you're not
allergic like if you have severe
anaphylactic attacks to these things
it's gonna take much less than that
gotta [__] ton of bees
oh that's just mean to the bees too this
is beehive tetherball
i can't do it anymore please put me
somewhere where there's no bees it's a
carbon dioxide dave doesn't understand
is that the more you freak out the more
you get stung idiot both of you are
idiots my friend i'm wee man and this is
the triple wedgie three
two no this is not gonna be good this is
not gonna be good
oh my god the perineum the area between
the testicular region and the anus is
particularly sensitive to injury and if
it does get cut you're going to get a
mean infection there that's an area you
don't want an infection a little angel
hanging in the air not doctor approved
look at the reservoir tip at least he
knows what the reservoir tip is the area
that we allow semen to go into so it
doesn't pop the condom i'm lubing up the
little toy car what is he gonna do with
the car because i'm going to put it in
my butt why though you're gonna watch
this you're making me uncomfortable what
is the purpose of the stethoscope you're
going to listen to the butt you know how
many patients do this and then lose the
object inside of them and then have to
come into the hospital to get like an
emergency colonoscopy or a flexible sink
i was partying last night with some frat
guys i passed out i must have fallen
down and broken something because i
haven't been able to walk right since
we're gonna take x right now okay to be
sure first of all no good doctor will
ever do an x-ray without doing a proper
physical exam
how did the cartway get there maybe you
stuck it up your ass i didn't stick
anything on my ass have you ever seen
anything like that no i never seen that
in there
what is this doctor's advice oh my god
is he getting these though and you're
putting honey on me and salmon
oh talk to it aaron try to calm it down
oh no it's going for the salmon oh did
he consent to this
mr bear eat that dick
do i need to say that that's not
medically safe a little different than
bear your bear yeah bear come here this
is what a nice bear feels like bad do i
taste like honey and salmon emotional
support complete i am johnny the
magnificent today i'm going to wow you
with my supreme skills of crested
vegetation
that's a hamstring tear did he get a
concussion he didn't even mess around
dude he turned around and just nailed it
yeah
oh seats that hit of the head onto the
floor that really knocked him out
looks like he has a broken arm
hello there how are you good what's new
uh clavicle baby broken wrist broken rib
concussion but i was supposed to pour
the milk in the hat and then put the hat
back on and no milk come out did milk
come out there's some milk on the pan
painful to watch but you know what's
more painful these painful medical
devices i cannot believe some of these
were actually approved for use click
here to check that out as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]
you